إنه بالطبع حلم كل صحفي
أن يقابل ملكة إنجلترا بشكل جيد
، لم يحدث أبدًا أقرب ما حصلت
عليه كمراسلة لجلالة الملكة في عام 2007
عندما منحتني تكريمًا مدنيًا
يُعرف باسم CBE جيدًا ، وكانت هذه
تجربة رائعة بالنسبة لي  ويمكنك أن
ترى من الصور وأعود إلى
الوراء وأتذكر الآن كم كنت متوترة كم كنت
أتوقع قدرًا من الترقب كنت
أقف هناك ما اعتقدت أنه
بدلة بيضاء جميلة تم
تجعدها قليلاً في الواقع كنت أرتدي قبعة اعتقدت أنني
ارتديتها  كان رائعًا حقًا كان علي أن أرتدي
قبعة لكنها كانت تشبه إلى حد ما
برج بيزا المائل كريستيان أمانبور
لخدمات الصحافة وكنت أخشى
أن تسقط عندما
انحنى أمامها قبل أن
تعلق الميدالية و  الشريط إلى طية صدر السترة الخاصة بي
وقيل لي إنك تعلم أن تشركها
بسرعة بشكل متحرك وتخرج من هناك
وتقرر متى تتحدث
معك وعندما ترفضك ، لذلك
تحدثت معها بسرعة عن الخيول
وأنا أعلم أنني حصلت على ذلك  كانت لديها هذا
الشغف وشكرتها أيضًا على افتتاح
مكتب CNN هنا في لندن في نوفمبر 2001 ،
والذي كان بعد فترة وجيزة من الاضطرابات
والانفجار العالمي الذي تسبب فيه 9
11 وقد أتت إلى CNN وكان
ذلك شيئًا لا يصدق بالنسبة لنا  في CNN ، لذلك
شكرتها على فعل ذلك لأنني كنت في
كابول في الوقت الذي كانت فيه في
المكتب ،
فأنت تعلم أنه كان يتم إخباري دائمًا أنه
بغض النظر عن عدد المرات التي رأيت فيها الملكة
على شاشة التلفزيون أو في صور الملك الراحل
.  أصبحت الابنة
الملكة إليزابيث الثانية ملكة إنجلترا ، لا شيء يجهزك تمامًا
للشيء الحقيقي وقد حصلت
عليه هناك ومن ثم اتصالها
وقوة الحضور وتلك
البشرة المتوهجة الشفافة التي كانت
مشهورة جدًا لأنك حصلت عليها حقًا عندما
رأيتها في  اللحم